Neonicotinoids are the most widely used
insecticide in the world.
We know that they have negative effects
on bees’ health.
From: Growth disorders,
reduced efficiency in the immune system,
to limiting the lifespan of the queen bee.
It’s been difficult to pin down sweeping effects
on bee populations but now researchers
have found more evidence for
another way neonics affect bees:
by contaminating their honey.
198 honey samples from around the world
were collected through a citizen science project.
75% of the samples tested positive for neonicotinoids.
Contamination was prevalent all over the world.
This confirms that bees are exposed to
neonics in their food.
Researchers say the contamination is too low
to hurt humans consuming the honey,
but that a significantly detrimental effect
on bees is likely.
What’s more--45% of honey samples showed
contamination from multiple types of neonics.
The combined effects of these pesticides on bees
is just starting to be explored.
This global picture of neonicotinoid contamination
should be useful to policy makers who are considering
the risks and benefits of using the pesticides.
Researchers hope these findings will persuade
authorities to make publicly available
data on neonic usage.
Then correlative studies can be conducted to determine
the relationship between the use of these pesticides
and the current decline of global bee populations.